il est temps à présent de passer à notre
chronique ce soir william el est avec
nous pour vous parler des dernières
actions du département dans sa royale
consorts florin tout à fait durant un
mois de mai plusieurs conventions ont
été signées par le département en faveur
de l'insertion sociale on va commencer
par le chantier et hall le 10 mai
dernier à nanterre la sncf réseau
lagence activity du département des
yvelines et le département des
hauts-de-seine ont signé une convention
sur l'emploi sur le chantier alors
petite présentation de ce chantier
titanesque de 55 km de long pour le
prolongement du rer e vers l'ouest
parisien un chantier qui va générer plus
de 80 mille emplois dont trente mille
emplois directs entre le début des
travaux en 2016 et sa mise en service en
2022 à mantes la jolie on écoute xavier
grouse le directeur du projet
l'objectif pour nous c'est de signer une
charte pour l'insertion des personnes en
difficulté donc cette insertion vise les
personnes qui sont les chômeurs de
longue durée les jeunes qui n'ont jamais
accès à l'emploi et toutes les personnes
qui ont vraiment du mal à trouver du
travail est ce qu'on peut dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui 7 % des heures
travaillées 7% des heures des personnes
sur le chantier seront à réaliser par
des personnes qui bénéficieront de ces
clauses d'insertion 7% c'est à la fois
peu et beaucoup c'est beaucoup pour une
opération de cette taille là et ça
paraîtra vraiment à de nombreuses
personnes aujourd'hui de revenir dans le
monde du travail
donc l'objectif premier réinsérer les
personnes les plus éloignées du monde du
travail dans les yvelines c'est l'
agence activity qui sera chargé sur le
territoire de repérer recruté et envoyé
en formation les allocataires qui seront
susceptibles de travailler pour les
entreprises du bâtiment sur ce chantier
ce groupement d'intérêt public
travaillera directement avec les acteurs
locaux du monde du travail comme la caf
et pôle emploi en tout ce sont 700 mille
heures de travail que se répartiront les
deux départements pour l'instant il est
difficile de donner un chiffre en termes
de nombre de contrats même si pierre
bédier le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines qualifie
cette démarche cette démarche pardon de
socialement exemplaires on l'écouté
c'est d'abord la démarche d'insertion
professionnelle qui nous intéresse
puisque
ce sera les attributaires du rsa
yvelinois qui seront prioritaires pour
l'accès aux 7 % d'heures réservé sur le
chantier au processus d'insertion
cpournous effectivement un moment
important et puis c'est un moment aussi
important parce que hall va desservir le
nord des yvelines le nom des yvelines
qui est le plus touché aujourd'hui par
la crise économique et qui est donc la
partie du département qui a le plus
grand nombre de bénéficiaires du rsa
alors ça c'est l'une des conventions
mais ce n'est pas la seule il y en a
d'autres tout à fait le département ne
s'arrête pas là deux jours plus tard
c'était à versailles via l' agence
activity toujours qu'on était signé
trois autres conventions la première
avec l'état la seconde avec pôle emploi
et la troisième avec la caf quels sont
les objectifs de ces conventions alors
le but ça reste toujours le retour à
l'emploi des bénéficiaires du rsa ici ce
sont 5000 bénéficiaires qui devrait être
remis en activité sur les 31 mille que
compte le département des yvelines les
trois priorités seront de renforcer les
personnaliser les parcours vers l'emploi
accroître le nombre d'offres d'insertion
professionnelle et de s'appuyer sur les
potentiels des territoires en coopérant
étroitement avec les acteurs
territoriaux
d'abord le conseil départemental pas
ouvrir 500 emplois 500 emplois aidés
donc ce ne sont pas des emplois
définitive c'est une façon de remettre
en situation de réussir des personnes
qui aujourd'hui sont au chômage en perdu
confiance en elle donc ce sont des
contrats à durée limitée des contrats de
réinsertion
donc l'objectif est donc d'aider les
yvelinois les plus en difficulté tout en
réduisant le nombre d'allocataires du
revenu de solidarité de solidarité
active la caf va quant à elle tripler le
nombre d'accompagnements de familles
monoparentales passant à 6 à 3000 pour
2016 entre activity des pôles emploi
c'est une collaboration qui permet une
prise en charge simultanée l'objectif
est ici doublé en 2005 en 2015 pardon me
600 personnes ont été suivies contre
3000 en 2016 un accompagnement autant
social que professionnel
sur les 1600 bénéficiaires du rsa
accompagné en 2015 par le binôme
activity pôle emploi 33% 3 33% d'entre
eux ont pu obtenir soit un emploi soit
une formation en moins de six mois mais
cette insertion sociale ne passe pas
seulement par la création d'emplois non
justement ici lagence activity joue sur
tous les tableaux dans le département
des yvelines certaines zones rurales
sont peu ou mal desservies par les
transports le permis de conduire est
donc obligatoire pour travailler un
précieux sésame aujourd'hui difficile à
obtenir que ce soit à cause du coût de
la formation ou de la difficulté de
l'examen et c'est pour ça que la
première auto école sociale a été créé à
versailles en décembre dernier alors
comment fonctionne cet écueil cette
auto-école sociale alors ça vient d'une
initiative du département qui a
missionné l'association sauvegarde de
l'enfant de l'adolescent et des adultes
des yvelines pour sa création c'est
grâce à un dispositif partenarial porté
par le conseil départemental est soutenu
par le fonds social européen à hauteur
de 200 mille euros que cette auto est
qu'aux est que cette auto-école pardon
la première dans les yvelines a pu voir
le jour dans cette auto-école la
formation et peu coûteuse puisque
seulement 250 euros minimum sont
demandés à chaque participant nous avons
rencontré sophie qui a bénéficié de
cette formation
dans une haute école classique on
corrige pas quoi ils nous disent pas nos
erreurs s'est on voit là encore y joue
en à faumont sais pas pourquoi alors
qu'ici nous explique pour quelles
raisons la faut cette auto-école est
donc adaptée au profil de chacun les
groupes sont réduits pour
l'apprentissage du code et les heures
sont adaptés également en fonction de
l'emploi du temps des participants
depuis décembre 2015 20 personnes ont
débuté la formation et déjà quatre ont
obtenu leur permis une réussite pour le
département qui prévoit l'ouverture d'un
second centre à mantes la jolie dans les
mois à venir merci williams pour toutes
ces informations pas